what is it the drawers readers to
science fiction my own feeling is that
science fiction is the relevant literary
form for today of all the different
types of fiction science fiction is the
only one which takes as its basic
assumption that societies are going to
change and which sets its stories
against a different a fundamentally
different society is something with with
great differences in it whether it's
time travel whether it's overcrowded
miss whether it's space travel whatever
it's not the present Society and there
was a phrase you used and I think what
was your first your very first novel you
talked about the aqua powers of darkness
is that is the whole question of magic
and and fantasy and mystery and myth
what brings people to it as well some
people have that theory but I don't I
think because there is real fantasy now
there is there are the Christmas the
Lord of the Rings that trilogy there is
water dokyun one watership down right
now is an excellent fantasy by fellow
called atoms people who want that can
still find it undiluted no I think
science fiction refers to different
societies which are connected to ours
through scientific and technological
change there is always that feeling that
we are heading right now rapidly into
changing societies people who are young
people today know that when they're
middle-aged life will be nothing by what
it is now
and science fiction gives them an
opportunity to try on different
societies it's the only thing that's
relevant anything which deals with the
world of today is going to be have no
meaning to young people of today when
say 30 years
you